sévérité extrême sur les routes un
avertissement du ministre de l'intérieur
à la veille des grands retours vers
andrew young après sa démission
spectaculaire le représentant américain
à l'onu s'explique pour entériner
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir si vous
revenez de vacances demeurent rappelez
vous que ce sera la journée la plus
difficile sur les routes bison futé vous
recommande donc à nouveau de ne pas
entrer en voiture demain d'ailleurs le
trafic est redevenu normal à la sncf
depuis ce matin 8h et le train est un
moyen de locomotion fort commode à ce
propos une dépêche me dis que plus de
650 mille voyageurs sont attendus dans
les gares parisiennes
au cours du prochain week-end c'est à
dire samedi dimanche cela dit si vous
devez absolument prendre le volant
alors partez dès les petites heures de
la nuit ou alors attendez 15 heures
demain et surtout soyez prudent le
nombre d accidents de la route en france
a augmenté de façon inquiétante en
juillet par rapport à la même période de
soixante dix huit
ainsi le nombre des tués a été de 10%
supérieur à ce qu'il avait été l'an
dernier ne vous étonnez donc pas dans
ces conditions veut trouver désormais
les mesures de surveillance très
renforcée
monsieur christian bonnet ministre de
l'intérieur qui était la risée d'antenne
de midi aujourd'hui n'a laissé planer
aucun doute sur les motifs de sa
politique de sévérité
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire qu'il fallait
défendre les français contre les autres
mais savoir aussi les défendre contre
eux mêmes
et comme nous avons au mois de juillet
constaté un nombre d'accident supérieur
à celui de l'année dernière que nous
avons dénombré 118 morts de plus et 16
129 blessés de plus dont certains jeunes
sont très gravement handicapé pour le
reste de leur vie
j'ai cette semaine donné des directives
aux préfets pour que soit renforcé les
mesures de surveillance et les sanctions
et pour ma part entre l'hécatombe des
permis de conduire dont plus de 4000 ont
déjà été retirés depuis le début de cet
été
et l'hécatombe des vies humaines j'ai
fait mon choix que tous les
automobilistes qui vont prendre la route
pour rentrer pour partir
les vacanciers de septembre ou
simplement pour vaquer à leurs
occupations habituelles soit bien
prévenu qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui la
sévérité sera singulièrement renforcé et
qu'il n'y a pas de mansuétude à attendre
monsieur venait dans la même mission en
2010 s'est élevée contre les campagnes
réclamant l'acquisition de kannad heures
supplémentaires pour lutter contre des
incendies de forêt disant je vais couper
les ailes un canard on ne construit plus
de canadair la chaîne est arrêté si la
construction devait reprendre
aujourd'hui il ne sortirait que dans
deux ans la campagne menée actuellement
est le fait de gens qui parlent de ce
qu'ils ignorent at il ajouté notant que
vers 17 heures les canadairs ont dû
intervenir aujourd'hui contre un
incendie à coarraze dans l'arrière pays
niçois
monsieur françois mitterrand à la suite
des émissions pirates du parti
socialiste des émissions radio riposte a
été inculpé de violation du monopole de
radiodiffusion en vertu de l'art
klose 33 de la loi du 7 août 1974 au
terme d'une après midi mouvementé
monsieur mitterrand a tenu à l'assemblée
nationale une conférence de presse
conférence au cours de laquelle il a
insisté sur l'aspect politique de la
paix une foule tout à fait inhabituelle
aux alentours du palais de justice cet
après midi des élus socialistes mer aux
députés des militants sympathisants
venus manifester leur soutien à françois
mitterrand laurent fabius et le sénateur
bernard parmentier convoqué chez le
doyen des juges d'intruction du rejet le
camp les 15h30 lorsque tous les
applaudissements françois mitterrand ses
deux amis tentent de franchir les
grilles du palais de justice
ils auront du mal vous voyez à se frayer
un chemin dans la foule les journalistes
et photographes contenu par un important
cordon de policiers messieurs mitterrand
fabius est un entier sont entourés de
leur avocat maître badinter roland dumas
et beauzelle
ils sont accompagnés par gaston defferre
le président du groupe parlementaire
socialiste à sa sortie françois
mitterrand qui a été inculpé ainsi que
ses deux amis fait une conférence de
presse à l'assemblée nationale
l'histoire de la france il ya toujours
eu des moments où des hommes ont dû
prendre des risques pour la liberté
or aujourd'hui il existe détournement de
la loi sur le monopole audiovisuel une
atteinte grave à la liberté de la presse
une fraude permanente sur le service
public de la radio télévision et bien je
le dis avec force les auteurs de ces
manquements sont le président de la
république et son gouvernement
c'est pourquoi le parti socialiste a
décidé de lancer une vaste éventail afin
que l'opinion se rendent compte à quel
point est menacée dans notre pays la
liberté d'information
le procès qui commence n'est pas celui
qu'on veut instruire contre le parti
socialiste et son premier secrétaire il
est celui que les socialistes eux
s'engagent contre l'arbitraire et
l'illégalité des agissements du pouvoir
politique actuel
on a voulu un procès politique
on l'aura le parti socialiste
cible des attaques parce qu'il est le
parti de la relève et de l'espoir
continuera son action tant que ne sera
pas respecté la liberté de la presse
dans notre pays
pendant ce temps là la troisième
émission de radio en poste devait être
diffusé à l'initiative de la fédération
socialiste du département du calvados
là il ya deux versions le parti
socialiste dit qu'elle aurait commencé à
15h45
mais qu'elles étaient brouillées et
inaudible la direction générale de tdf
c'est-à-dire télédiffusion de france
explique de son côté il n'y a pas eu des
missions car des moyens techniques la
radio socialistes ont été déficient
voilà trois ans presque jour pour jour
monsieur giscard d'estaing confier les
fonctions de premier ministre et
monsieur raymond barre jusqu'à la
ministre du commerce extérieur monsieur
bart avait dit que l'on jugerait des
résultats de sa politique au bout de
trois ans
nous y sommes seulement en trois ans la
situation internationale a
considérablement varier elle a
évidemment rejaillit sur la situation en
france
les critiques de l'opposition à
l'encontre de monsieur bart sont
néanmoins très vive et où rpr on
critique également les résultats du
premier ministre pour l'udf en revanche
monsieur bart l'a nullement démérité
comme l'a expliqué daniel brême le
délégué général monsieur michel pas
c'est vrai que nous ne pensions pas au
tintamarre parce qu'il me paraît tout à
fait artificielle mais nous travaillons
sérieusement essayant de parier en toute
sérénité la rentrée nous préparons notre
programme d'action pour la prochaine
fois les années à venir et nous n'avons
aucune difficulté à signer le premier
ministre a simple raison que nous avons
toujours soutenu sa politique parce que
nous paraît nécessaire
nous continuons à la pensée nécessaire
même si sur cet appel nous parle pas
suffisante où en serions nous si le
premier ministre n'est pas que les
mesures qu'il a prises depuis trois ans
s'il n'est pas maintenu la parité du
franc avec les grandes monnaies
étrangères
notre pays aujourd'hui serait à la
catastrophe ce qu'on oublie de dire
aujourd'hui quand on critique raymond
bas vous donner le plus souvent
l'impression d'être solidaire du chef de
l'état que du premier ministre
c'est pour une raison très simple le
chef de l'état représente de valéry
giscard d'estaing représente la
permanence n'est ce pas et l'udf soutien
valéry giscard d'estaing notamment dans
ces grandes options
le premier ministre présente la gestion
quotidienne des affaires et nous le
soutenons parce que il reprit le va dans
le sens que désire prison la république
mais les premiers ministres pas c'est le
présent et public reste vous ne craignez
pas que l'inquiétude des français sur le
pouvoir d'achat et le chômage permettent
à la gauche d'augmenter ses partisans
écoutez ça fait trois ans que l'on dit
sort or je constate d'une part que la
majorité a gagné élections après
élections législatives d'abord
européenne ensuite qu'il n'y a pas eu de
défection d'un lectorat et je constate
d'autre part que les trois dernières
années de gouvernement ont été parmi les
plus calmes qu'on ait connu sur le front
social
en ce qui concerne les en oeuvre par
exemple alors je crois avant tout que
les français sont raisonnables qu'ils
ont du bon sens qui savent que la
situation difficile ou sur notre pays a
des efforts à faire et que tout le
tintamarre d'aubagne et à l'heure qui
est fait aujourd'hui autour de quelques
difficultés conjoncturelles
les français savent très bien que ceux
ci est inévitable ils savent très bien
reconnaît ce qui est important d ce qui
est accessoire
quand même payer que cette situation il
y aura des tensions la situation est
difficile tout le monde le dit bien sûr
fait ce chemin difficile mais de là à
être inquiet à coire une explosion une
marge
et ça je ne crois pas du tout explosion
je crois que les français savent trop
bien dans quelle situation nous sommes
iran les combats contre la ville kurde
de deux sacs aise à la frontière avec
l'iran ont fait près de 200 morts
cette ville de 50 mille habitants est
totalement encerclé et survolée en
permanence par l'aviation iranienne
les kurdes affirment qu'ils peuvent
résister longtemps et qu'aucun d'eux en
tout cas ne s'est rallié à l'appel de
l'ayatollah comédie
pour sa première apparition depuis la
fin du ramadan l'ayatollah khomeini
s'est adressé aux kurdes
livrez-nous les traîtres et les
comploteurs at il dit et vous serez
pardonner il a demandé aussi à l'armée
de tout faire pour écraser la rébellion
déjà l'ordre règne à sanandaj la
capitale du kurdistan
les combattants kurdes les peshmergas
ont rejoint leurs compagnons dans la
montagne douce organisent la résistance
et la ville est entièrement sous le
contrôle des gardiens de la révolution
de l'ayatollah khomeiny dans le monde
entier les cures de s'organise et parle
de génocide de leur peuple à paris à
l'église saint-géry une vingtaine de
représentants de la petite communauté
kurde de france ont commencé ce matin
une grève de la faim pour protester
contre l'intervention massive de l'armée
iranienne
les kurdes on a lutté pendant des
décennies depuis l'époque du parti shas
les achats début de siècle
et puis on a lutté contre les chats on a
offert beaucoup de matières pendant ces
sept les dernières 30 années et
maintenant aussi on voit que ça de
guerre continue contre les cultes cette
extermination de sa veuve qui réclame
toujours sa liberté en moins son
autonomie dans le cadre de liron c'est à
dire que vous espériez obtenir
l'autonomie après le départ du shah
d'iran a on était certain de ça mais
c'est qu'on voit maintenant c'est
vraiment un fou parce que khomeiny
n'attaque pas seulement de l'étude mais
mais aussi tous les mouvements
progressistes laïque et démocratique
il interdit tous les journaux qui qui
réclament la liberté pour le peuple
on a l'impression aujourd'hui que le
peuple kurde est complètement isolé
c'est à dire qu'en irak
on a étouffé la rébellion en turquie
aussi est maintenant en iran oui le
peuple kurde était toujours isolée et
c'est aussi avec les accords concertée
entre les états qui partagent ce que dit
on par exemple dernièrement il ya eu des
accords entre l'irak et la turquie
il a eu un accord pour réprimer ces
rebelles et les empêcher de s'infiltrer
dans la turquie l'armée iranienne ces
prêts de 400 mille hommes vous combien
êtes vous est ce que vous pensez pouvoir
résister longtemps
et bien si on compte les éléments armés
occupent dix ans surtout après le départ
du shah beaucoup de qnd en
nous prévoyons et le l'hégémonie de
khomeiny qui est allé s'imposer sur tous
les pays
ben ils se sont munis d'armes beaucoup
de familles vendent leurs biens pour se
procurer des armes pour se défendre quoi
pendant ce temps les verts communiquent
continue à menacer de ce peloton
d'exécution tous ceux qui ne le
soutiennent pas on peut dire que ce
sommet ni tel qu'on le découvre dans sa
réalité quotidienne est très différent
de ce qu'il semble être
il y a quelques mois à l'époque de
neauphle-le-château en fait pris dans la
rapidité avec laquelle les événements
brut se succèdent
nous sommes contraints parfois nous
autres gens de l'actualité de présenter
l'information au jour le jour donc sans
prendre le recul nécessaire et
l'envoyait dans l'ayatollah un homme
d'une tout autre stature en fait il en
est souvent un cidre de révolution car
une chose est pour un leader de
combattre vraiment un régime détesté
mais c'est une tout autre chose que se
retrouver à conduire les affaires de
l'état comme nous l'a enseigné à maintes
reprises l'histoire un commentaire de
georges bortoli souvenez vous au mois de
janvier dernier la petite ville de
neauphle le château abrite est le plus
illustre des émigrés l'ayatollah comédie
la destinée de l'iran reposait entre les
mains de ce vieillard presque
octogénaire l'occident découvrait la
puissance d'un homme seul la fidélité
fanatiques de ses partisans et
l'incroyable vitalité de l'islam qui
assimile kilomètres de la jeter les
foules d'iraniennes sur les canons des
mitrailleuses
le contrat c'était fantastique ici ce
vieillard en babouches dans son pavillon
de banlieue et là bas le chat avec ses
trésors sa police et son armée le chat
incapable de résister aux ordres de
soulèvement du petit vieux alors on se
méfier bien un petit peu en analysant le
discours de communi à discours qui était
un petit peu rétrograde mais si on se
méfier on rêvait aussi beaucoup on se
disait que grâce à commenee l'iran livre
est jusque là
l'industrialisation sauvage alors si
l'utilisation à tout va l'iran allait
retrouver sa véritable identité
et puis et puis nous ont vu que ce
n'était pas vrai bien sûr il y avait une
part de vérité
car le petit peuple des faubourgs de
téhéran car le petit agriculteur
misérable traînant sa charrue en bois se
sont identifiés effectivement à comme
eni et peut-être malgré tout ce qui va
très mal en iran continue à s'identifier
à lui dans une certaine mesure certains
d'entre eux en tout cas mais quand nous
avons vu rappeler vous tous ses tiroirs
empilés dans les tiroirs de la mort
comme avons vu les libertés bafouées et
nous avons vu les minorités nationales
les kurdes bafouée elle aussi alors à ce
moment là nous avons été cruellement
déçus nous avons commencé à nous dire
nous journalistes que l'ayatollah au
fond nous avait trompés ou bien plutôt
soyons honnêtes que nous nous étions
trompés nous mêmes car nous avions fait
une erreur très vieille très habituelle
qui consiste à croire quand une tyrannie
renversé c'est un peu plus de liberté
qui va s'installer ça n'est pas vrai du
tout quand une tyrannie s'en va ça peut
très bien être une autre tyrannique
arrive vous rappeler la rupture de
barrage en art il ya quinze jours selon
notre confrère le times of india le
nombre de victimes serait de 40
le président carter vient de prendre une
semaine de vacances une croisière sur le
mississippi or il a prononcé 58 discours
soit en moyenne une allocution toutes
les trois heures jour et nuit à
plusieurs reprises il a réitéré
l'engagement de washington de parvenir à
un règlement d'ensemble négocier au
proche orient
à l'onu le conseil de sécurité a repris
son débat sur la question du président
palestinien
les etats-unis ont rappelé pour leur
part qu'ils étaient décidés à utiliser
leur droit de veto contre tout texte qui
reconnaîtrait aux palestiniens je cite
le droit à une existence nationale
structurer les débats au conseil
continuent à être menées pour le moment
par monsieur yang ambassadeur des
etats-unis à l'onu bien qu'il soit
démissionnaire c'est un homme dont on a
beaucoup parlé depuis une dizaine de
jours à propos de ses contacts avec les
représentants de boeing à new york et de
ses critiques de la politique de
monsieur carter mais on n'avait guère
entendu lui-même
pour antenne de l'ambassade et ryang a
confié ses projets d'avenir est notre
envoyé spécial permanent jaksic en tant
que simple citoyen je pourrais faire
désormais tout autant sinon plus pour
infléchir la politique du gouvernement
américain que lorsque j'étais
ambassadeur
d'ailleurs je n'ai aucune intention de
quitter la politique mais je m'en
occuperai désormais comme simple citoyen
en ce qui concerne l'ol paie ce qui est
très important pour vous est-ce que vous
avez l'impression d'avoir progressé
je crois que nous avons avancé pour ce
qui est d'encourager une approche
réaliste du problème palestinien de la
part du gouvernement américain
je crois que nous n'avons pas le choix
et j'espère amener le gouvernement à
s'en apercevoir il ya quelques jours
nous étions à harlem et les noirs
étaient très en colère à cause de vos
problèmes
pensez vous qu'ils vont vous soutenir à
fond ce suisse outil aussi par beaucoup
de blancs et même par des juifs
ce n'est pas un problème des noirs
contre les blancs ou des noirs contre
les juifs
il s'agit d'un problème de droits
humains pour une partie oubliée de la
population mondiale
c'est une idée dont le moment est arrivé
pour citer un français célèbre pensez
vous que votre problème vient du fait
que vous êtes noir
non le problème ce que j'ai fait ce en
quoi je croyais et non pas ce que mon
gouvernement m'a dit de faire le nombre
des réfugiés à deux chinois a
sensiblement diminué en août par rapport
à juillet mais le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés des nations unies rappelle
qu'il n'ya pas que les indochinois
il y a par exemple les dizaines de
milliers d'éthiopiens qui se réfugient
au kenya et en somalie
il ya ceux de la guinée équatoriale qui
après le récent changement de régime se
réfugier au gabon ce dirt daisy qui
cherchent refuge au mozambique où il y
en a déjà plusieurs reprises en 2010
pour en revenir à ceux du sud est
asiatique 1600 d'entre eux auront été
écrit par la ville de paris d'ici la fin
du mois leur situation sociale sont très
diverses paysans militaires
fonctionnaires etc
tous n'ont pas forcément de famille en
france mais pour tous il faut apprendre
à changer de vie et cela peut être
allons d'apprentissage car se réadapter
dans un pays étranger aussi accueillant
soit-il n'est pas chose facile tout est
changé tout est nouveau tout semble
étrange
14 quai pour repartir à zéro quand on a
connu que les collines du nord la hausse
il faut d'abord réapprendre à compter la
plupart de ces réfugiés hmong sont
illettrés dans leur propre langue
à l'exception d'un seul il était
instituteur
d'abord il faut que je vais apprendre et
leur chance et millet et après j'ai
quand je comprends pas ce que je vais
faire
vous ne savez pas encore ce que vous
allez faire non vous voulez travailler
en ville où travailler dans la campagne
je veux travailler un vilain c'est mieux
bien sûr cela ne sera pas facile il
fallait fuir la disette et les
emprisonnements arbitraires qu'il faut
maintenant reprendre des forces
subir des contrôles médicaux ceux ci
sont arrivés la semaine dernière
d'autres groupes sont attendus presque
quotidiennement jusqu'à la fin du mois
la plupart rejoindront les centres
d'hébergement de france terre d'asile en
province seule une minorité pourra
trouver du travail dans l'agglomération
parisienne
c'est le cas de ce professeur ancien
capitaine de l'armée sud vietnamiennes
rescapés de poules au bidon longue avec
ses six enfants avec l'aide de la mairie
de paris
je suis sûr que je pourrais trouver un
travail dans la région de paris ces
années dans la banlieue de paris
quel genre de travail
selon mes aptitudes ou alors on bosse
gardiennage
ces adresses studieusement calligraphié
un miracle peut-être celui qui
permettrait de retrouver le fils perdus
pendant l'exode ou un vieil oncle
installé en france depuis longtemps en
lisant ces affiches
un jeune cambodgienne et au vietnam a pu
retrouver un cousin qui l'avait précédé
et qui maintenant les berges
je suis arrivé à ford il y en a
tellement j'étais d'abord hébergée par
les amis et ensuite grâce aux annonces
je vais trouver l'emploi national et
maintenant j'ai très heureux de recevoir
mon cousin qui vient d'arriver
qu'at-il l'intention de faire un taux
réel est à bad santa anna il a
l'intention d'apprendre le français
le français beaucoup de ceux qui sont
arrivés en france depuis quatre ans le
parle suffisamment pour mener une vie
normale sans bruit mais non sans effort
les auront pu faire comme ces nouveaux
habitants du xiiie arrondissement
une épicerie un hlm un terrain de jeu
bien sûr personne n'a oublié mais la vie
tels a repris madame charles de gaulle a
quitté l'hôpital du val de grâce où elle
avait subi il ya un mois une
intervention chirurgicale
elle a regagné l'immaculée conception de
notre dame de lourdes dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris où elle réside
depuis le début de l'année et où l'on
déclare charles de gaulle est entré en
convalescence
le directeur de l'hebdomadaire ouest
allemand à grand tirage des chevilles
monsieur ouch times a été arrêté un
serbe n sous l'accusation de détention
de stupéfiants alors qu'il s'apprêtait à
rentrer hambourg après ses vacances
on a trouvé dans ses bagages 40 grammes
de chanvre indien
une vedette du théâtre bolchoï de moscou
le danseur étoile alexandre grenoble a
demandé hier l'asile politique aux
autorités américaines les circonstances
dans lesquelles il a quitté la troupe
qui effectue actuellement une tournée
triomphale là bas sont inconnues les
pousses de 2,9 qui fait également partie
du bolchoï n'a pas demandé
contrairement à son mari à bénéficier du
droit d'asile
ce n'est pas la première fois en tout
cas qu'un danseur soviétique choisit de
ne pas rentrer dans son pays
un commentaire de gérard holtz
apparemment les autorités soviétiques
n'avaient pas une grande confiance en
alexandre godounov après chaque
représentation du bolchoï à new york par
exemple une voiture venait spécialement
le chercher au théâtre et puis il faut
se souvenir aussi qu'il s'est rendu très
rarement à l'étranger ces dernières
années partenaire habituel de maïa
plissetskaïa dans carmen et anna
karénine en particulier ne l'avait
jamais accompagné en tournée
sauf une fois à paris cette année pour
danser avec elle un seul soir
carmen alexandre godounov danseur étoile
29 ans l'une des grandes vedettes du
bolchoï de moscou a donc décidé de se
réfugier à l'ouest en revanche sa femme
qui fait aussi partie de la tournée ne
semble pas avoir demandé l'asile
politique aux etats unis
c'est la quatrième fois qu'un danseur
soviétique célèbre se transforme ainsi
en étoile filante
avant lui rudolph noureev en 61 à paris
natalia makarova en 1970 sa longue et
mickaël baryshnikov 174 au canada
en avait fait autant il est fort
possible d'ailleurs qu'alexandre
godounov veuille travailler maintenant
avec son ami baryshnikov sport les
tennismen français n'ont pas été
favorisé par le tirage au sort des
séries des championnats open des états
unis qui va commencer à flushing meadows
près de new york dès le premier tour en
effet pascal porte encore à stan smith
yannick noah sera opposé au vainqueur du
match qui vaquent carmichael et gilles
mort et on se retrouvera face à claire
face à l'izk l'air tête de série numéro
10 a noté un fait sans précédent les
organisateurs ont décidé de classer
board tête de série numéro 1 alors que
le tenant du titre jimmy connors mais
que tête de série numéro 2 c'est la
première fois que la logique l'emportent
sur la couture patinage artistique le
grand prix international de
saint-gervais en haute-savoie se déroule
en ce moment dans un paysage de glaciers
naturellement dans le passé ce tournoi a
souvent sorti de future grande vedette
en danse sur glace victoire des
canadiens mademoiselle au point et
monsieur pagnacco est en couple victoire
des américains mademoiselle et monsieur
karoutchi frères et soeurs un extrait de
la compétition avec le commentaire de
jambes
il
une allégresse d'ordre
maintenant
synchro dit également
nous avions déjà vu et qui manifestement
et fred en province d'un colis et bien
entendu la victoire ne peut leur
échapper dans cette épreuve paris saint
germain retrouvera peut-être aux jeux
olympiques
là les couches la météo pour demain dans
le nord est des alpes à la corse on
observera encore quelques averses le
matin suivi d'éclaircies un temps
couvert apic pluie abordera la bretagne
et s'étendre à la normandie au val de
loire et à l'aborder puis l'après-midi
ou le soir au bassin parisien et à
l'aquitaine
les éclaircies apparaîtront très de
l'atlantique où les vents de nord ouest
deviendront assez fort à l'avant de la
zone pluvieuse le temps sera
généralement ensoleillé avec quelques
passages nuageux
les températures resteront inférieures
aux normales mais dans tout cela n'y a
pas de quoi comme dit l'autre écrire à
la famille à vers 22h30 c'est hervé
claude qui vous donnera les dernières
informations de la journée demain
n'oubliez pas samedi et demi avec daniel
bilalian entouré d'historiens car nous
parlerons villa diantre parlera des
dernières semaines d'août 1939
celle qui a 40 ans menait à la deuxième
guerre mondiale
et si tel est toujours votre bon plaisir
nous nous retrouverons de m'asseoir à
blatter bonsoir
à